now the two of you you hadn't worked
together before magic no but I hear an
you were very very excited to work with
Matthew
I was excited her yeah I mean you
wouldn't be he's amazing yeah yeah yeah
I was excited to work with him but tell
the people why you were excited to work
with Matthew well there are a few
reasons I had been fan for you know a
while like like many people and I
remember sitting down with Chris he to
talk about the film he said he'd written
a new screenplay and he told me the
story and I thought it's had an amazing
and I said well that the lead role
sounds unbelievable who you're gonna
cast in it and he said well I've been
thinking about Matthew McConaughey and
you know everybody flashback this is in
early 2013 so the McConnell sense hasn't
happened yet so we haven't you know
woken up to the genius of this man yet
and he and he goes oh you you think
that's a that's a good idea have you
seen mud and I said no it's a Magic Mike
Chris goes oh yeah well most people
who've seen mud think that you I'm just
like Magic Mike Magic Mike the
performance and Chris is like oh and
then he clearly wants to move the
conversation along and I will not shut
up
how much I love Matthew in that film
you're so good in that movie cuz yes
it's like it's hot and sexy and you
thrust and stuff but you also is such an
incredible character and it's so deep
and he's scary and he's funny and he's
like ha he's also so skeevy and it's
just it's like and I remember I walked
out of the theater and you know this I
walked out of the theater and I turned
all my friends cuz we all went to see it
together and I said Matthew McConaughey
is gonna win an Oscar and I knew it the
second I saw you like pressed up in that
I'm breakdancing
the camera shooting up your Cobra
codpiece and that man is going
me through all of us to say well we knew
you were gonna win it but how did you
feel on the night
why IRA had no I had no idea because
everyone must be kind of blowing smoke
up you were kind of going you've got her
in the back no no no no no i sat there
and i remember they think they start to
say the names and music people came up
came up and I think I I went through the
names could if anyone had other names
start with a nut
I left through when they did in I think
that's me I look at my wife it was here
we go because a picture is an amazing
picture of the moment you hear and you
do look like you me going through anyone
elses name start with a ma and also you
know what else is really lovely better
because what are the chances of the two
of you being here together look how
happy and Hathaway is that you've won
nicely you've been mean scowling and
then this would be really awkward
yeah so we were arguing and I just sort
of lost it out and I said Oh sharp
monkey feet